bene a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono tornato dopo
6.000 anni su uno perché effettivamente
è un gameplay che merita tantissimo e
oggi sono col gatto con pietro e con
ciccio non so cosa fruscii fuori dalla
roba del genere però buona visione
allora adesso vi spiego un po come
funziona avete dei bellissimi avatar
allora ragazzi c'è questa modalità che
si chiama pesca a strascico ma adesso io
ve la spiego pietro la conosce bene l'ho
sentito dopo una cura ride allora
praticamente funziona che ogni volta che
non peschi che non hai le carte da
giocare continui a pescare finché non è
che non puoi buttare giù per la bocca e
questa partita durerà fino alle 5
iniziamo chi vince verrà bannato dal
canale mio
quindi spero di prendere me stesso cioè
ci ho capito che ha perso il grande
problema
pecca io ho già 65 carte contino
ragazzino no no no no la pesca a
strascico che culo e colore vuole ma io
faremo un bel giallo ma non è un
problema ecco lei grazie tieni ciccio
riccio tra loro il volto noto cadrà
anche un turno perché lei è un
fischietto ma basta ragazzi orribile a
posto sfidare i più quattro
non so in che modo non ho capito privo
di qos fida perché mi fido è sbagliato
ho perso sei suite sfida lei non si fida
che io ho bisogno di fare cambio colore
a ok ma siamo già lo sapete bene questa
la vinco io si contano ma io ribadisco
che il ma basta ma basta telomeri loro
mi sfidi non mi ricordo le carte non me
ne ricordo nomi ma non ce l'aveva il
giallo non ce l'avevo non ce l'aveva già
vista
ora penserò a strascico molto a lei come
uno anche l'oro è vicino all 1 vero
vista lei vinca ma non può averla sempre
non ce l'avrà sempre ce l'ha tocca a
pescare che non c'era però per hobby ma
che culo ma non ci crede selezione
lo posso anticipare non so come cosa
vuol dire posso anticipare lo so il
verde è sbagliato
devo ripescare quindi va bene ma basta
dire è impossibile fare qualcosa ciccio
kitsch e pesca perfetto clara ciccio
quanto incassato nella nel bayern è
quello sono io adesso io non ho niente
di che può dare anticipo cosa vuol dire
anticipo ma non lo so strascico
divertire non so il colore io cambiano
ma sono scemo no non lo sapevo che ne
sapevo io e non me lo ricordavo più lo
ricordavo mi ricordavo niente sono scemo
mi spiace scusate vabbé fa niente beh il
video spero vi sia piaciuto
facciamo due contro due normale
due p 24 22 e come si fa a giocare il 22
che ne solo mette il problema l'ho fatto
io queste due i due però il giorno che
non sai come ci si mette in 22
lui fa dove non scegliamo conquistare va
bene giochiamo questi giochi incontri 2
contro 2 attivissimo io sono per il
gatto pagherei signor gatto si impegni
come sempre dovessi farlo io prego a
come si gioca non so come si gioca
ho capito ma non ho capito come si gioca
qua e lui dice prima vincente ma perché
tu hai saltato ad usare meno come giallo
a ok scusi il pensavo di giallo la mia
carta gialla non potevo metterla
siamo fortissimi trovai che dirige il
signor gatto che un po beppe vessicchio
nel ballo
no attenzione proprio lui
grazie grande 4 no che sfiga pesa
proprio niente
la pesca a strascico signor gatto gioco
di giallo pressure lei come è scemo
regia per lei l'ho fatto
ighalo come non c'è il giallo e ce la
farà giallo sono stupido guardare come
era già giallo e non ho visto l'avevo
proprio capita io questa cosa
signor gatto non ho niente lo stupendo
vero ma non importa basta ci capiamo
cosa povere abbassa che vinca uno dei
due occhi ok pietro che ciccio è un
casino
ecco come tu che stiamo pescando
veramente poco 16 come è il nostro
giocare come l'ho detto è la meriva
ancora no no
ok e alle volte che avete di pescara in
12.000 il titolo sarà il mio turno
eccolo lì qualche cumulo io non ho mai
niente che sfiga
la prima è sempre tutto quando secondo
gli altri no
è vero non lo so il 3 ma basta
cambiamo i colori per favore di apple è
ok grazie mille dopo avere tutte blu
basta fate sfiga però dai io 3d giallo è
giallo con rimette blu corretto il
giallo
va bene però guardi mi vede lei no ma
edizione a perché le donne che non c'era
dai però guardi qua e sono almeno loro è
di noi viene attaccata questa guardino
maledizione per bacco niente madonna
scusi è venuto da ridere
era impossibile questa sfida si farà ma
è pazzo ma avete un colore diverso
posso mettere l'uno non 6 3 che non è
giallo e adesso che ne sai
ecco cos'era era blera rosso maledizione
ma lei pure si è bruciato un p4 ma non è
questa roba erano parole si stagionali
strategia con l'a1 è uno quello siete
pazzi rosso che il signor gatto faccia
qualcosa è bravo a mantenere il rosso
nonostante tutto non mi sfidi bravissimo
neve ne sei proprio lui bravo signor
gatto mi è piaciuta st giocata una paio
ne un problema di gioco questo
associando la giochiamo
bravo bravo bravo proprio bella bella
bella
sarò io 5
bravo gioca così si gioca così sono due
che mancano cosa fa mi cambia colore
pazzo ma ho capito ma sta giocando da
psicologico lennon capino mi segue non
mi segue io gioco psicologico ma stia
tranquillo sto troppo sofferto più di
quattro fantasy viii doppio di otto
pesco 16 carte
non mi cambiare la maledizione
psicologico non ha funzionato
una via che ci c'è un'attenzione nome
sociale norme sul giallo se è pazzo
attenzione non giallo a 11 giallo è
anaya ed è per forza già aveva gialla e
non è detto è meno attenzione
no non è fare un cambio di colore nolo
pietro non farlo usarla è ma ho paura
che vivifica fallo fallo ma soprattutto
mi distrugge signor gatto si ogni atto
faccia qualcosa
prova aspetti aspetti attenzione sia
gatto
sì ma non ci ago no mi contesta ma tanto
il colore è cambiato
ok ok perché c'era che celava tutte
madonna che 3 bravo è stata ricercata
molto bene che non avrei avuto questa
pista e io poi professor layton signor
bravissimo bene grazie cambio colore o
lascio quello e capitolare pro rosso e
tirozzi no facciamo così non si è
affacciato 3 tanto di noi sono d'accordo
ma nome lei pazzo ma non faccia così ma
lasci perdere
non so se avevo in quest'ultimo a
pescare sempre quella giusta che culo
grazie a nei quartieri a di quei colpi
di carte giocate pietro tieni non gioca
non gioca ed ecco qui un bel 9 giallo
tensione ciccio e che faccio e gioca non
puoi fare molto
dove scaricare l'amico loro signor gatto
ha salvato la partita io se fossi stato
al posto suo avrei perso
pensavo andasse peggio effettivamente
però è pietro che destabilizza la gente
con cui l'ho sempre detto sta cosa
vediamo nel prossimo episodio perché lo
faremo per adesso ragazzi spero che vi
sia piaciuto iscrivetevi al canale
lasciate mi piace commento qui sotto
e noi come sempre ci viviamo ragazzi
[Musica]